if you want someone to like you more
there are some really specific
psychological things you can do that can
actually make a world of difference as a
relationship therapist I've literally
spent my career studying the art of
Attraction and human psychology so I
know that these things work the first
thing you're going to do is take
advantage of the reciprocal liking
concept when you see them in person you
are going to act so genuinely excited oh
my God I'm so excited to see you and
catch up on all the things we talked
about last time you're probably thinking
that Kimberly like shouldn't I be
playing it cool like shouldn't I be
waiting for them to come and talk to me
and the answer is absolutely not a new
paint with all the colors
gonna treat them like you have a very
special connection and this is because
our brains are psychologically primed to
like people more when we know that they
like us and think we're a good person I
mean seriously what is with the makeup
thing I don't understand why would you
record a video where you're putting
makeup on I've never been brushing my
teeth and said to myself you know oh
this would be great content